the water level at lake mead is
currently at a lowest it's been since
the reservoir was filled and today it
dropped below 1060 feet for the first
time ever there's a lot of concern that
it could drop even lower than expected
this year because of a proposal to keep
more water in utah's lake powell now
that would send less water down the
colorado river to lake mead a decision
on that could come before the end of the
month so for some perspective here's a
look at it a side by side comparison
water levels here in year 2000 and now
water levels here last summer in the
june of 2021. these towers actually no
longer hidden they're no longer
underwater so how is this going to
impact our state well right now we're
under a water shortage for sure but it's
not noticeable for us because nevada
already uses less water than what we're
actually going to be cut to
we're also not likely to use any lose
any power produced by hoover dam just
yet because water levels would need to
drop another 100 feet in order for that
to happen now with that said though the
water authority reminds everyone we are
in a water crisis so conserve water
wherever you can brian denise